Marvel has just confirmed two major
amazing theories that I know marvel fans
are going to be really happy about these
two theories have major implications for
the MCU of course connecting to Phase 5
phase six and setting up Avengers the
King Dynasty and Avengers Secret Wars in
a recent interview where these theories
were confirmed by somebody from Marvel
we learn that Kang is quite possibly a
lot stronger than we thought he was and
has quite possibly been around in the
MCU for a lot longer than we thought so
the first theory is something that fans
have been wondering about for a while
now what some people are referring to as
the new Infinity Stones which aren't
exactly Infinity Stones per se but sort
of Kang's Infinity Stones we're talking
about the 10 Rings Kamala Khan's Bengal
and whatever other crazy artifacts of
Kang are out there in the universe or
universes right now many believe that
they are indeed connected to Kang and
that he he probably made them himself
especially after seeing a lot of
resemblance between the tin rings and
the rings around Kang's Quantum City
well now we have an official answer on
whether they're connected or if it's
just something us fans are trying to
make connect in our heads which we love
to do and I am especially guilty of
I'm sorry
but this time it's legit they are indeed
connected Avengers 5 the Kang Dynasty
writer Jeff loveness has confirmed this
in a recent interview with backstory
magazine he confirmed our theories and
has also hinted that Kang is a lot more
powerful than we think and has been
involved in the MCU for a lot longer
than we know and like I said what he
says here in this interview has some
serious implications for the future of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe here's the
first part that he said relating to the
first theory in this interview in the
interview when he was asked about the
scene in Loki where he who remains was
explaining that different variants were
trading technology and helping each
other he stated this yeah I mean that I
guess ties into a bigger King question
in general of like what is his
technology what makes him such an
existential threat what makes Kang
similar to each other and unique and
then the Rick and Morty guy me is going
okay you also just don't want to rip off
the portal gun or like the Rick
technology or whatever and for those of
you who may not know Jeff loveness was a
writer for Rick and Morty so he's
basically trying to not give Kang the
same technology that Rick and Morty had
in the show but he goes on to say but
like yeah and I guess this gets into
spoiler territory but I'm sure people
have picked up the fact of like oh he
has ring technology that's interesting
or he's got oh those glyphs look a
little similar so I think we'll be
seeing that Kang has had his
fingerprints on the MCU for a long time
now ring technology is obviously
referring to Xiang Chi and the legend of
the ten Rings the actual 10 rings and he
talks about the glyphs looking very
similar now obviously he is confirming
here that they are indeed connected to
Kang while speaking about technology he
confirms this is basically King Tech and
we can probably assume since the Bengal
is very similar that it is as well he
confirms this by 10 telling us that
we're going to be seeing that Kang has
had his fingerprints on the MCU for a
long time so that was him confirming the
first theory that us fans have been
having for a pretty long time now about
Shang Chi's Rings the Bengal Etc and
we'll get into the second theory in just
a bit but first we have to talk about
something in this first Theory okay so
first of all the Rings and the Bengal
are indeed technology of Kang or kangs
this makes sense Kang is a time traveler
him and possibly other variants of his
have been all across our timeline at
different points in time possibly giving
weapons to people who can influence
worldly events to make things go his way
or possibly simply leaving weapons
behind whether that's on purpose or
accident either way people of Earth like
the Mandarin got their hands on some
awesome Tech from King this is now
confirmed second of all he says Kang has
had his fingerprints on the MCU for a
long time this is great to hear and I
look forward to seeing exactly how
Kangas influenced Earth because remember
Kang let everything happen he who
remains a variant of Kang and possibly
the same King who we saw in Ant-Man
quantumania he could become he who
remains that is he made the TVA and
eliminated any timeline that drifted
from the sacred timeline if you recall
Loki tried to blame the Avengers or
break in the tva's laws because they're
the ones who went back in time however
in court ravana rensslayer says that the
Avengers going back in time was supposed
to happen so therefore Kang let Thanos
snap he let the Avengers go back in time
come back and defeat Thanos and then let
Captain America go back in time and stay
back in time and then come back again
and then live on the moon apparently so
I can't wait to see what Kang has been
truly involved with but this also solves
a problem that a lot of fans have been
having lately with the MCU which is it
not being that connect
many people have complained that the MCU
isn't that connected lately and that
most things are one-off and don't really
tie into the bigger connected picture
well showing us that Kang has secretly
been involved in everything that has
happened not only recently but from all
the way back in phase one is certainly a
great way to really connect everything
together and hopefully since Avengers
Kang Dynasty is a story about Kang we'll
find out a lot about what he's done and
is doing now the second theory that was
confirmed in this interview is a
Fantastic Four Theory Jeff loveness went
on in the interview to say this speaking
about Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
he said and if you saw the end credit
scene teleporting in looked very similar
to someone else as well from Multiverse
of Madness so like I think there is a
concerted effort to kind of tie some of
his technology language together but
without saying too much I suppose but
he's been all over now of course who he
is referring to here from Multiverse of
Madness and the teleporting is read
Richard so this confirms that Kang is
indeed connected to Reed Richards aka Mr
Fantastic and this just makes sense if
you're a comic fan or if you followed
the channel you know that Kang whose
real name is Nathaniel Richards is
believed to be a descendant of Reed
Richards so it is possible that at some
point speaking just of the MCU here not
in the comics but at some point Reed
could have had invented some technology
for teleportation and Kang could have
possibly stolen it from his distant
relative Kang originally came in contact
with the Fantastic Four in the comics
where he first traveled back in time to
ancient Egypt where he became the ruler
Rama Tut until that is a Time displaced
Fantastic Four appeared and defeated him
causing him to leave that time this
sparked a hate in Kang for the Fantastic
Four and later on The Avengers this
could be the case in the MCU as well and
Kang could have stolen Reed's Technology
Long his way of trying to destroy the
Fantastic Four but regardless of how
either Reed or Kang got their technology
Avengers 5 the King Dynasty writer Jeff
loveness just confirmed that they are
indeed connected to each other so what
do these theories all mean well they
mean that a lot is secretly happening
right now in the background of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that we don't
know about that is eventually going to
be shown Kang has clearly been involved
in the events of time in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and has most likely
influenced major events in History
either by using the TVA or he himself
interfering we don't know if the
Fantastic Four have been having
superhero adventures in the background
either but since Kevin feige Marvel
Studios as president has already come
out and said that the Fantastic Four
movie won't be a true origin story we
could possibly assume that they've been
in the background doing something and
that maybe caught the attention of Kang
which further links him to the occurring
events of the MCU and there is one thing
about this interview and that Jeff
specifically he says that caught my
attention and made me think wait what
yes this makes sense and that is
speaking about how the other kangs at
first would exchange technology with
each other he was talking about Kang's
technology and then asked what makes
Kang similar to each other and unique
this is where we have to realize that
much like what we saw in Ant-Man
quantumania in the post-credits scene
there are a lot of kangs that get along
and they interact with each other we
learn from he who remains that Kings
originally helped each other and shared
this technology so King as very advanced
technology already on his own but could
also have Tech from other universes that
he got from other kings or by killing
other kings in their respected universes
that could be way greater than anything
we've seen in our universe and I am
personally really looking forward to
seeing what King has up his sleeve but
let us know your thoughts in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe so you
can stay up to date on all the latest
MCU Theory and news and of course you
can always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof